le 19/20 continue voici le rappel des
titres mikhaïl gorbatchev
confronté à la crise la plus meurtrière
depuis son accession au pouvoir les
affrontements continuent en azerbaïdjan
la grève dans les hôpitaux les internes
et chefs de clinique menacent de faire
la grève des urgences réactions dans ce
journal d'un chef de clinique et de
montpellier
le gouvernement lance un train de
mesures financières pour aider les
stations de sports d'hiver toujours
privé de neige enfin nous verrons à la
fin de ce journal les plus beaux essais
marqués au cours de la septième journée
de championnat de france de rugby mais
tout de suite l'actualité à l'étranger
en allemagne de l'est le gouvernement
obligé de céder à la pression de
l'opinion publique
harcelé par l'opinion donc et par
l'opposition qui continue la population
de descendre dans la rue les autorités
notamment hans modrow ont satisfait
aujourd'hui nombre de revendications
principalement celles à l'encontre de la
statue
oui alors aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de manifestants ont dévasté
les locaux de la police secrète de
nouveaux incidents incontrôlable survenu
au moment où la justice durci le ton
le ton envers les anciens dirigeants
l'ex numéro 1 erich honecker est accusé
de haute trahison
nathalie darrigrand
nous sommes le peuple nous sommes le
peuple crie ses milliers de berlinois
cent mille personnes selon la télévision
qui ont littéralement pris d'assaut le
siège de la police secrète la stasi une
foule visiblement résolu à s'attaquer
aux symboles d'un régime qu'elle vaut
aujourd'hui voir disparaître une
certaine violence les vitres du bâtiment
ont été brisées les meubles jeté par les
fenêtres
l'appel au calme des membres du
mouvement d'opposition nouveau forum n'a
pas été entendu mais la police sur place
n'est pas intervenu parmi les
manifestants certains arboraient le
drapeau ouest allemand l'état de guerre
en azerbaïdjan les affrontements de
nature ethnique et surtout nationalistes
qui ont engendré le massacre d'une
cinquantaine d'arméniens depuis samedi
dernier ces affrontements mettre
directement en cours l'unité de l'union
soviétique et fatalement la réussite à
terme de la pérestroïka alors
aujourd'hui les affrontements se sont
poursuivies tandis que plusieurs
centaines d'arméniens de la capitale de
l'azerbaïdjan ont commencé à être
évacués
le point de la situation avec en gros je
dispose de 48 heures après le début des
pogroms anti-arméniens moscou est
finalement sortie de son apathie cet
après midi avec la réunion du présidium
du soviet suprême
cette fois merengues en batch heures
semble bien décidé à faire face à la
crise va technique la plus sanglante
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
une crise d'autant plus embarrassante
pour le leader soviétique elle remet
directement en cause cette tutelle dans
le caucase après avoir tenté de piller
le siège du comité central ce week-end
et nationalistes azéri appellent
ouvertement à la sécession
côté arménien les réactions semblent
moins radicales pour l'instant presque
que la communauté qui condamne la
passivité de moscou a préféré court
circuiter le pouvoir central et faire
face seul car les violences continuent
en azerbaïdjan le bilan des pogroms
anti-arméniens s'élève provisoirement à
34 morts à bakou la capitale
l'évacuation des femmes et des enfants a
commencé par des maritimes
six cent soixante d'entre eux ont pris
la fuite via la mer caspienne 200 autres
ont été placés sous protection
sur place les autorités auraient perdu
le contrôle de la situation dans
plusieurs régions les renforts envoyés
par moscou s'avère impuissant
impossible d'atteindre les zones de
combats la population bloquent leur
progression ce soir le présidium du
soviet suprême a décrété l'état
d'urgence
en albanie maintenant difficile de
connaître avec précision la situation
politique dans l'un des pays les plus
fermés d'europe
l'état d'urgence décrété par les
autorités ne peut pour l'instant être
confirmée nos envoyés spéciaux gens peu
perpère et marque doux sont en ce moment
même à la frontière albano yougoslave
près de titograd des témoignages qu'ils
ont recueillies ne permettent pas de
percevoir un éventuel bruits de botte
dans cette région enfermés derrière ces
montagnes d'albanie ne laisse filtrer
que d'infimes bribes d'informations sur
son repliement au passage de la
frontière a beau zahia 20 km au sud de
titograd la route semble se heurter aux
barrières et aux chicanes du poste de
police albanais que nous avons filmé en
fraude aucune silhouette de garde de
douaniers n'apparaît aux abords du
bâtiment
chaque véhicule qui franchit
no-man's-land à temps par connaisseurs
avant que la barrière ne se lève en fait
le trafic se réduit à quatre ou cinq
camions par jour et à moins d'une
dizaine de personnes surtout les
albanais qui après de longues démarches
ont obtenu l'autorisation d'aller rendre
visite à leur famille et amiens
yougoslavie comme ici au village de
toucy hommes 50% et 7000 habitants sont
d'origine albanaise les renseignements
en provenance d'albanie sont colportées
par ces voyageurs d'isoler ou comme ces
derniers temps par des transfuges mais
ces informations sont impossibles à
vérifier souvent très sujette à caution
il y a une tension en albanie en ce
moment et
à quoi ça va ressembler sera
certainement pas une norme à nice si
nous voulons que les visiteurs ne sont
enregistrées par les médias yougoslave
en voici des extraits mais la langue de
bois et l
il est difficile d'y trouver une
information objective pour les
observateurs et yougoslavie ici il ne
fait aucun doute que les albanais
supporte avec de moins en moins de
résignation le régime stalinien de
tirana le bouclage de leur pays n'a pu
arrêter les images des événements de
roumanie dernièrement diffusé jusque
dans leurs foyers par les télévisions
grecques que yougoslave et italiennes et
c'est là un puissant ferment de révolte
le reste de l'actualité internationale
en bref maintenant voici les télégrammes
de l'étranger préparer commenter ce soir
par caroline fonte
à berlin-est les négociations entre le
pc l'opposition se sont interrompus à
cause justement de l'invasion des locaux
de la station
le premier ministre hans modrow y
assister depuis ce matin il avait promis
que tous les documents concernant la
dissolution de la police politique
serait rendue publique
et ce soir la justice est allemande
annonce qu'eric honecker ex-président de
la rda et que l'expo chef de la stasi
sont poursuivi pour haute trahison et
conspiration anti constitutionnel
ce matin le parlement bulgare a aboli le
rôle dirigeant du pc en revanche la
bulgarie reste une république populaire
socialiste
les députés ont également voté la
mystique pour les bulgares d'origine
turque
ceux ci peuvent reprendre leurs montures
qui est parler leur langue cela leur
était interdit depuis quatre ans après
l'ouverture des négociations pour le
départ des troupes soviétiques de la
tchécoslovaquie
hier six mille personnes ont manifesté
en moravie pour qu'il ne reste plus un
seul soldat en août prochain
le retrait aura plus vraisemblablement
lieu à la fin de l'année soixante quinze
mille soldats soviétiques vivent dans le
pays depuis l'invasion de 68
a bologne une bombe a explosé dans un
bureau de poste 44 personnes sont
blessées trois hommes armés étaient
venus pour un hold up
ils ont voulu ouvrir les coffres forts
avec la bombe celle ci a explosé trop
tôt
trois blessés sont dans un état grave
social les internes et chefs de clinique
ses médecins en fin de formation dans
les hôpitaux publics les internes dans
quelle échelle de cliniques sont en
grève nationale ils protestent contre
leurs futures conditions d'installation
en médecine libérale et ils réclament
l'ouverture très rapide de négociations
avec les pouvoirs publics oui menace
même de faire la grève des urgences dont
les prochains jours alors de son côté le
ministre de la santé claude evin déclare
ne pas être en mesure de satisfaire
leurs exigences
les négociations entre la caisse
d'assurance maladie et les syndicats
doivent reprendre de toute urgence
réclame le ministre martin désilets la
menace d'une grève des urgences plaint
toujours ce soir sur le secteur
hospitalier
les internes et chefs de clinique en
grève nationale depuis ce matin pourrait
bien durcir leur mouvement
ici à paris ils sont toujours à l'heure
actuelle en assemblée générale le
problème posé celui de l'installation en
secteur 2 pour ces internes et chefs de
clinique en fin de formation
c'est à dire pouvoir pratiquer des
honoraires libres
un médecin généraliste ou spécialiste
peut en effet choisir entre deux formes
d'exercice de la médecine soit il
appliquer strictement les tarifs de la
sécurité sociale et bénéficient en
contrepartie d'avantagés fiscaux
c'est le secteur 1 soit ils optent pour
le fameux secteur 2 où il pourra
librement fixer le montant de ses
honoraires
ils sont 26% en moyenne en france dans
ce cas mais 60% en région parisienne
dans certaines régions d'ailleurs il
devient très difficile de trouver des
médecins pratiquant le tarif normal le
secteur de qui a beaucoup progressé ces
dernières années pourrait donc bien être
gelée d'où la colère de ces internes et
chefs de clinique qui en appelle à leur
ministre de la santé claude evin
considère que ce conflit est du ressort
de la négociation conventionnelle c'est
à dire de la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie qui a reçu ce matin
les syndicats d'un terne et de chef de
clinique
mais les grévistes demandent l'ouverture
de négociations avec les pouvoirs
publics pour désamorcer le mouvement que
des vins indiqué ce soir qu'il allait
recevoir une seconde fois les
représentants syndicaux de cette
profession alors le dr pas ghana
le président des internes de montpellier
et en direct depuis la station et air 3
languedoc
monsieur paganin goût parler de l'avenir
mais le gouvernement vous réponds
médecine de classe tout à fait avant de
t'engager des problèmes techniques je
voudrais simplement dire que les
internes et les chefs de clinique que
sont en grève nationale aujourd'hui et
demain car notre avenir est en jeu et
nous sommes aussi inquiet pour l'avenir
domino malades
justement quand vous parler d'avenir le
gouvernement vous dis médecine de classe
est-ce que vous ne risquez pas avec ce
mouvement finalement vous rendre très
impopulaire parce que sont les usagers
qui en souffrent pas du tout dans la
mesure où notre mouvement recueille
large consensus de la part des syndicats
de médecins généralistes de médecins
spécialistes et du corps professoral
il s'agit pour nous bien plus qu'une que
mouvement corporatiste car notre action
vise à défendre un principe fondamental
qui est le libre choix du médecin par
sont malades et la lie le libre choix du
lieu d'installation par le médecin
monsieur paganin vous ne répondez pas
tout à fait à ma question que les
usagers finalement les plus fortunés
peuvent être soignés et que ceux qui le
sont moins ne peuvent pas l'être
pas du tout car actuellement ciblé le
problème du secteur donné un problème
d'urgence
nous demandons pour maintenir une
médecine de qualité la revalorisation du
secteur 1 il faut savoir que si et des
médecins sont passés en secteur 2 c pour
amortir matériel qui est nécessaire au
plateau technique est nécessaire au
maintien de la qualité des soins pour
nous nous demandons une revalorisation
de l'ami des actes conventionnés et le
gel du secteur 2 n'est qu'un principe
d'urgence avant la signature de la
prochaine convention
alors vous demander l'intervention des
pouvoirs publics le ministre a réaffirmé
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement n'a pas
légalement le pouvoir d'intervenir
vous allez faire la grève des urgences
vous allez prendre en otage les malades
il n'est pas question de prendre en
otage les malades nous sommes d'abord
médecin avant d'être grévistes et
syndicalistes les urgences seront de
toute façon assuré par le service
minimum prévu par la loi
donc il n'est absolument pas à l'ordre
du jour
jour de prendre les malades comme otages
merci monsieur pagaille pour ce
témoignage donc en direct de montpellier
l'état saupoudre de mesures financières
les stations de sports d'hiver privé de
neige l'absence de flocons pour la
troisième année consécutive constitue un
manque à gagner important pour toutes
les entreprises où toutes les communes
qui ont investi massivement souvent dans
ce secteur au cours des dernières années
alors aujourd'hui le ministre du
tourisme s'est rendu sur place pour
annoncer cette série de mesures jugées
insuffisantes par les professionnels de
la neige ces derniers espéraient que la
procédure de catastrophe naturelle
serait déclenchée
clément weill raynal ce n'est tout de
même pas de la faute du gouvernement
s'il ne neige pas a plaidé olivier stirn
face au mécontentement des
professionnels et des élus qui estiment
insuffisantes les mesures en faveur des
stations de sports d'hiver annoncée
aujourd'hui par le ministre du tourisme
victime pour la troisième année
consécutive d'un manque de neige les
stations de sports d'hiver se considère
comme sinistrés quelle que soit la suite
de la saison
on estime que le chiffre d'affaires de
ce secteur qui emploie cent mille
personnes en france que ce chiffre
d'affaires sera en baisse cette année de
25 % par rapport à l'an dernier
sur les 36 station de l'isère seuls deux
l'alpe d'huez et les deux alpes ont pu
faire fonctionner certaines de leurs
pistes de ski le ministre du tourisme
olivier stirn a donc annoncé toute une
série dette gouvernementale sur le plan
fiscal des délais sans pénalités seront
accordés aux entreprises des subventions
et des avances de trésorerie seront
également octroyés mais au cas par cas
nettement insuffisant plaident les
professionnels qui auraient préféré que
l'on déclenche la procédure de
catastrophe naturelle il y a un côté sam
en une prise de conscience et une
volonté d'agir
par contre nous avons une déception qui
sera partagé je pense par la plupart des
agents économiques
ceux qui sont en difficulté sur le
terrain aujourd'hui
immédiatement c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'
aides de trésorerie à taux bonifiés le
ministre du tourisme qui a précisé que
d'autres mesures seraient prises si le
manque de neige persistent a par
ailleurs souhaité qu'une politique
globale de la montagne soit élaboré un
conseil national de la montagne doit se
tenir à ce sujet la semaine prochaine à
matignon un accident de car mortels ce
matin dans l'aube un quart militaire
conduit par un appelait s'est déporté
pour une raison inconnue
il a violemment heurté deux à trois
adolescents ont été tués et huit autres
blessés le car transportait des enfants
de militaires qui se rendaient en classe
à trois le brouillard est peut-être à
l'origine de ce terrible accident
survenu ce matin vers 7 heures sur la
nationale 77
voici à présent le tour de france de
l'actualité en bref avec les
commentaires ce soir de nathalie et r
jean marie et christine villemin à
nouveau entendu pour deux jours par le
juge simon
c'est plutôt inhabituel le coup est
arrivé sous la protection d'une
importante escorte de policiers certains
portaient même un gilet pare balles
un tel dispositif laisserait supposer
que le couple villemin et reçu des
menaces de mort
un mort dans l'accident du mirage 2000
qui s'est écrasé cet après midi près de
l'aéroport de bordeaux mérignac
l'appareil avait quitté les
établissements marcel dassault et venait
de décoller lorsqu'il s'est soudain
écrasé dans la forêt le mirage 2000 est
un chasseur multirôle qui équipent les
forces aériennes françaises
le sénateur rpr pierre carous s'est
donné la mort hier matin à son domicile
de valenciennes maire de cette ville
pendant 41 ans
il avait été réélu en 83 mais n'avait
pas achevé son mandat également sénateur
depuis 1955
pierre carous ça a toujours été un
gaulliste convaincu il est mort à l'âge
de 76 ans miracle en la cathédrale de
nancy hier après-midi un pyromane a
allumé cinq foyers dans les 10 6
à commencer par la crèche fait de paille
et de papier si le dessous de la crèche
a entièrement flamber les flammes se
sont arrêtés juste devant le petit jésus
un panneau de bois représentant la
sainte vierge a également été épargné
avouez que c'est plutôt troublant
football daniel hechter n'est plus
président du racing club de strasbourg
uds a démissionné cet après midi avec
tout le comité de gestion du club
alsacien c'est un nouvel épisode du
différend qui l'oppose qui emporte donc
le couturier parisien à la municipalité
c'est au cours d'une conférence de
presse mercredi prochain que daniel
hechter expliquera les raisons son
départ le couturier parisien et lyon 86
avaient été priés de quitter son poste
le mois dernier par le maire de
strasbourg après un audit comptable
annonçant un déficit de cas de plus de
89 millions de francs des chiffres
contestés par daniel hechter rugby in
chronic qui prend tout doucement sa
place dans le 19/20 et que vous
retrouverez bientôt le dimanche celle
des plus beaux essais du championnat
france à noter surtout la belle
performance de dax face à grenoble dax
qui reste le seul club invaincu
jean philippe guillin est dit bourgoin
refait surface et s'impose devant
biarritz ne pas 3 grâce à l'unique essai
berjallien un essai conclu par le 3e
ligne c'est sion
mais cette rencontre a surtout été
marquée par la sortie de serge blanco
peu après la mi temps l'arrière
international qui souffre des adducteurs
a dû déclarer forfait cet après midi
pour le match d'ouverture des cinq
nations face au pays de galles
blanco cède sa place à jean baptiste
lafond le racing man autorise si d'un
superbe plaquage sur l'arrière de bègles
bordeaux bègles l'emportent 12 à 0 les
joueurs n'ont pas hésité à se prouver
longuement leur amitié au cours de la
rencontre
gif le pin baignent les pruneaux voler
bas allons messieurs un peu de tonus sur
le terrain que diable dax grenoble
le duel des invaincus a tourné à
l'avantagé des dacquois très soudée
derrière un pack dominateur les blancs
marquent deux essais et profite ici
d'une double erreur des lignes arrières
chrono boîte pour conclure score final
20 à 9 pour dax enfin tout le monde sur
ses terres a régalé les spectateurs du
stade mayol de quatre essais devant
lourdes et toulonnais irrésistible à
l'image ici d'eric chambre qui offre un
essai à son compère du pack chaput si le
cinq de devant a fait un super match
les trois quarts ont joué au diapason
c'est l'arrière jérôme bianchi
parfaitement décalé qui portera
l'estocade 29 à 12 pour toulon je vous
assure qu'on verra plus souvent les
belles images comme celles des
toulonnais marquant cet essai elle est
bien qui plutôt que celle du combat de
rue
en quelque sorte entre le racing et
bègles quelques images encore avant de
nous quitter d'automobiles celle des
premiers essais d'alain prost sur un
circuit française c'est au castellet
aujourd'hui à bord de sa ferrari toute
ronde bien sûr mais à côté de lui dans
une autre ferrari nigel mansell les deux
hommes vont poursuivre ses essais très
important pour la saison prochaine
jusqu'à la fin de semaine
très vite catherine le prochain rendez
vous d'information prochain rendez vous
la fois 22h30 sort trop facile de voir
la météo complète de michel tourenne
nous vous retrouverons demain excellente
soirée à demain sur la péniche